This is a great. Damn, my life. What are you talking about lowering
myself? And I tend to agree. This is the best content Mizkif's
ever produced. I sent my ops to the courtroom for Tectone and
And I have written down notes for a 7-hour trial. I didn't say
a word last night. I didn't want anyone to know. I have 7 hours
of notes on Tectone and what he did to Pinkchyu. Tectone has
a protective order from Pinkchyu. For the next 10 years, Tectone
can't own guns. That's why Tectone deleted that tweet.
So, Shemu came in with this tweet. Tectone was in court today
regarding a protective order to stop harassing and stay away
from his ex. Given that he's been dead silent since court, I
don't believe it went well for him at all. That was at 4:28 p.m.
Pacific, okay? Tectone then shortly after that, I
uh wait. No, no, no, not this one. This is the
tweeted this, okay? An hour an hour and a half later, Tectone
tweets this. What a good boy.
To make it seem like he wasn't just being silent on the court
case, okay? That's not the only tweet that went out at him, though.
We got a couple other tweets going out at this guy, all right?
We had Mizkif of all people getting in, throwing some elbows.
Let me go to Mizkif. Is it real Mizkif? Real Mizkif on the Twitter
timeline?
Real Mizkif?
Oh, let's go. Miss Andy Black, nice.
This 2014? No way.
Mizkif says, "Are you sure about that?" This was the Tectone
tweet about it being a great day. And Mizkif says, he goes even
further. Might have to give get rid of that gun here.
Implying that maybe Tectone is a part of his protective order
might have to give up his guns. Maybe
somebody went to the courthouse and said, "Hey, this guy keeps
taking pictures with all kinds of guns. I feel like this is very
threatening to me."
And he he's in a two-man situation where maybe he has to surrender
his weapons.
Mizkif also tweeted this one out.
All right, implying he got rid of Lacari. Implying maybe maybe
or, you know, maybe just circumstance, possibly.
And then just a little while ago, he says, "Tectone was right.
Today was a good day. Still live on Kick, Eddie." Now, I don't
know if he goes any deeper, if he pulls any details. I don't
know what we have for details here, but I do think he talks about
it a little bit on his Kick stream. So, let's go ahead and try
to find that. This rascally guy, Mr.
When you have court today regarding a protective order to stop
harassing >> Ooh, there's the Shemu tweet. >> away
from his ex. Given that he has been dead silent since court,
I don't believe it went well for him. You know how there's a
lot of streamers,
There's some specific streamers that like to say, "I'm going
to wait until what court says."
Court spoke.
The court speak?
I still don't have a restraining order.
Why do you allow these idiots around you for so long? I have
not been friends with Tectone in like since the last Camp Knut.
And the reason why I stopped talking to him is because he [__]
on me and Victor because he was mad that we were making him use
a stripping pole. And he said that it's gay and stupid and that
he we're just using him for content.
When
that was literally what Camp Knut is. Like, who gives a We were
literally you using you for content because that's what we were
doing. Um
And he basically quit Camp Knut. And the whole time he was brigading
and saying how great Nick is as a person and how [__]
I am as a person because he wanted everyone to like Nick for
some reason because he just wanted me to hate. You want to know
why? Cuz he was in love with Emmy.
That's it. He loved Emmy and he hated I was dating her.
That's every All of Mizkif's problems are actually just that
everybody hates that he was dating Emmy, okay? Everybody wanted
Emmy. That's everyone who hates him, okay? They actually just
wanted Emmy. Actually, all of OTK were just Emmyru stalkers.
They were just more sophisticated Emmyru stalkers.
And he's a loser. So, he would literally berated me and attacked
me for a long period of time. He [__] on me. Uh he
claims the reason why I uh he hated me was because I got him
kicked out of OnlyFans and I called him
>> isn't true. Uh that wasn't the case. Um I did not I
did not say that. It was about one time in when I was in Japan,
uh there was a little there was a
thing or something and I said like, "Oh, look, uh Tectone would
like that or something." It was like a a kid game.
And it's like, but he literally plays games with kids all the
time. We literally saw him do a tier list yesterday of kids.
What the
He also uh That Tequila Sunset tweet coming in
Also, hold on. I don't know if I call
I don't know if I call that playing games with kids necessarily,
but all
>> little cesspool of friends were obsessed with her. Yeah,
let's let's write down the things that Tectone >> They
did get Ryan wedding, yeah. hated me for. So, he hated me for
I said he
He does.
But attacked me for it. I literally messaged Chance and said,
"What are we going to do about Tectone?"
Here's Chance literally when I said, "What are you doing about
Tectone?" I kicked Tectone out of OnlyFans. He would make procket
people uncomfortable. Oh, [__] He's playing >> if
he was in proximity voice.
Right here.
Actually, that's kind of a big leak. It's actually kind of a
big leak. God, I meant to do the crash sound effect.
It's actually a big leak.
That Sodapoppin's the one who kicked >> Chance kicking
him out of OnlyFans. Dude went around and told everyone it was
me.
He went around and said it was me. And told everyone I did it.
So, he lied. And the reason why he lied is he wanted everyone
and his chat to hate me. He wanted to perceive that I was trying
to keep him down, keep him under, and that I was trying to stop
him from having fun around Austin and do things. When I literally
don't even go out. I never hang out with people and I was just
sitting inside all day with Emmy and we were just playing games.
But Tectone is trying to make it seem like I wanted to ruin his
life and not let him around. When yes, Soda was 100% right. He
should have kicked Tectone because he made people uncomfortable
if he was in proximity chat. Of course, he would. Duh. No [__]
what? This is not an argument. This is a no [__]
I didn't kick him.
this is why Tectone hates me. Number
I said he likes loli games. He literally
He did a tier list on them.
And like like like he does. Like
Like, what is it? Like what kind of games are they?
VTuber games? I don't even know Oh, he doesn't know the name.
>> He's never heard of the kind of games.
Gacha games.
He said he likes VTuber And like he literally admitted that he
likes those kind of games. Like he likes type
VTuber
games. And I made a joke about it in Japan and he literally went
around uh
And he said I called him a on stream.
Then he hated me because I was dating Emmy. This is true. This
is 1,000% true.
This is 1,000% true that Tectone hated me because I was dating
Emmy. Uh he couldn't stand that I was dating Emmy and he was
in love with her. Um I have things I'm going to continue to show
you guys and prove to you that will prove that point. But yes,
he hated me because I was dating Emmy. Dude was weird. And he
was What? He's going to he's going to prove that Tectone was
in love with Emmyru? Let's go.
>> I heard from sources that he would talk about her in
a very weird manner with his dad, allegedly. So, he hated me
because Well, Pinkchyu >> Cuz Russell threw a pool party
in my backyard. He hated me for it. >> Oh, are we getting
the Pinkchyu Mizkif >> Uh his ex-girlfriend came over.
I shook her hand. Uh this is Pinkchyu. I literally just shook
her hand, okay?
And uh Pinkchyu.
Pinkchyu. He went through around uh
and said I was grabbed her hand for such a long time that I was
so weird and told everyone I'm weirdest for that. Making people
hate me. >> Pinkchyu. Which it did happen and people did
start to hate me because he was literally describing it as like
assault. I swear to god, he was mentioning it as assault. Basically,
I like forced my hand and grabbed her hand. Oh my god. Which
then she messaged me after like when like during all like this
like a year ago it was a catch up like, "You know, that never
happened. I've always wanted to message you and I'm so sorry
that he ever said that."
And then then her and I started talking a lot because we both
had trauma with Tectone because we were just depressed. Um this
girl went through so much dog [__] It's insane.
So, we we started to talk. Number five, he said that the reason
he got kicked from OnlyFans was rape tone, okay? >> This
is completely false.
And I've shown my receipts. Chance made the decision and it was
un uni You have? You have? >> lose her. Didn't kick you
out of [__] Literally, no one wanted you there. I
don't remember what it was. >> I'm skipping forward a little
bit here. >> I don't know if it was kink. I don't know
if it was about his dad. It was something. And he had these accusations
and no one was talking to Tectone anymore. So, that's when Tectone
went from playing gacha games to started to right-wing grift
because Tectone wanted to farm hate against everybody because
he's a bad little [__] And he started to farm hate
and get these the most ridiculous [__] viewers that
are just He's a bad little [__] He's deranged and
think that everything is just like what he says is godsend. What
he's literally the I don't know how anyone ever listened to this
guy in my life. I don't know how anyone ever listens to this
guy. He's the biggest [__] loser. I have ever seen
in my entire life.
Like he's the biggest loser. I never understand how anyone could
watch him for more than 1 second. You want to know something
else that's interesting? People didn't watch Techtone. That's
right. Techtone viewbotted hard. And when I say hard, I mean
70% of his community was [__] viewbotted.
Let's go. >> to know how I know? I have the receipts. I
have the receipts.
He's got the receipts. >> literally buying view bots and
asking people to buy him view bots with his name and his phone
number.
No, [__] Well, censor the phone number, please. I
think the name is kind of public information, but censor the
phone number, please. >> Show you? All right. You see what's
nice about me, chat? You know how I don't [__] just
act like I'm like uh I I'm Listen, you know what? If Mizkif shows
convincing receipts that Techtone is viewbotting, I will never
I will never make fun of demon time again, okay? I will not laugh
at demon time. I won't mock him for demon time. It will actually
be demon time. If he actually shows convincing receipts of Techtone
that's it. >> Well, well, I'm going to wait. I'm not going
to do this. Jerk off. Let me give me 5 minutes to look at my
phone. I'm going to find it. So, give me 5 minutes,
>> Give him 5 minutes to look at his phone. Holder, I need
to I
And he showed it? All right. Chilling, chilling, chilling, chilling,
chilling, chilling, chilling, chilling.
Ready? Elevate, time to complete your workout. Should believe.
Okay, thank god. This is Techtone's number. His name is John
Tecky Robertson. You're going to see that name a lot over the
next few days. The reason why it says Elevate, it's time to complete
your workout is because this was on my phone and I took these.
Uh so, I Well, these are screenshotted to me and for some reason
it says Elevate, okay? I'm just letting you know. Ready?
This is the bots that were bought. This is Techtone's account,
http/techtone, http/techtone, 2004, July 26, quantity 1,000.
Okay, hold on. He's not He's not zooming in very much. Let's
see here.
July 2024, 1,000 view bots.
And then, August 2024, 3,000 view bots. >> In August 4th,
quantity 750.
This is John Techtone.
Zoom in? Sure. This is John Techtone messaging the person that
was buying him the bots saying, "Sad face, can you try that again?
I'm stupid and dumb. You just make an account paid to the top
right and add it to your account. If you need help, let me know.
It's good for you to do it anyway since I won't be around. Let
me know if you need me to walk through it and I'll help you."
Which then they try to help him with secure paying, okay? Why
do you have these? Because I'm a [__] demon. And
when you [__] with me, I'm going to [__]
destroy you. These are the This is the bots that he bought, right?
This is August 24th,
Another time he bought bots. XDD, did you buy my bots with the
[__] orange ass emoji? You went 20. >> Dude,
ADHD runs me 619. Thank you for the five gifted. I believe that's
more time on the stream. I will see for sure.
Hello, well, just say like cuz I do my content, I need my own
space. Techtone probably [__] on her cuz it's true.
I'm going to do sets all over this house like role-playing in
the kitchen. Don't worry. Did you get my bots? So, Techtone definitely
needing her to buy the bots. I can only do 750, but I sent you
the link to everything. Sad face, can you try again?
Wait, her? Wait, her?
There's only a couple of hers in this story. This was what, 2024?
July 2024? Were him Were him and Fream still
I don't remember if him and Fream were still together. Did Did
they break up? Were they still together around December of 2024
or
No, I feel like her might be Fream. That's who I would expect.
>> stupid and dumb.
Good job, Techtone. You You are right. You watch Techtone. Okay.
This is the bots.
This is John Robertson. There's Techtone's picture. On August
24th, paying $1,000 claiming it's the house when it really was
for bots.
Why would Techtone pay $1,000 for a house that he owns?
Does that make any sense to anyone?
And then, these are the bots. This was taken on August 24th.
This was on my August 4th, he bought the bots starting at 70
quantity 750, quantity 1,000.
Zoom in more. There's no way I have to zoom in more. Like this
This is This is zoomed in. There you go.
Did you sell him the bots? Nope. This is not for me. This is
not for my phone. I just have the screenshots of the text messages
of John Robert Robertson trying to uh ask and make someone buy
bots for him cuz he's apparently too [__] stupid
to do it. So, this is him asking her to do this and he was making
her do it on her card which then so Techtone wouldn't get caught
and then Venmoing her with pictures of house emojis so that way
no one would know what it's for. Randomly giving her thousands
of dollars when he owns the house. How does that make sense?
Because he was
Thank you very much. This is one of many of the things that we
did to Techtone. This is like total Techtone destruction right
now, okay?
TTD,
Techtone is going down.
Is this actual confirmation? No, this could be fake, but Not
going to say. Listen, with those dates, we could go look up those
dates. Now, I have happen to know there's juicy stuff coming
down the pipeline that I need to be tuned in for. So, we're not
going to We're not going to keep looking into that right now.
We can look it up after, okay?
Oh, we'll find out who her was.
You will know. I didn't realize did Mizkif just come up with
this spur of the moment?
Like 2 HOURS INTO HIS STREAM, HE JUST DECIDED it was total Techtone
You want to go Do you want to pick up Pokimane bots from Techtone?
I would love to do that. Okay, then I'm going to go right now.
Do you want to meet us there? Uh yeah, sure. Text me. The address?
Yeah. All right, cool. Text me now. Here we go. Yes. Who was
the last streamer you jerked off to?
I don't
I don't even [__]
Nog, wait a minute. I have. Uh-huh. Take the shot, bro. Take
the shot. He says JERK OFF. OH MY GOD, that's crazy. You want
to know the worst part? I met Wait, what did he say? Take the
shot. >> He says jerk off.
I didn't even hear who. Hold on, I'm turning it down.
Nog, wait a minute. I have. Uh-huh.
Take the shot, bro. >> He just said it. Take the shot.
HE SAYS JERK OFF. OH MY GOD, that's crazy.
Wait. Oh, you take the shot if you're not going to say, right?
Uh I MET HER RECENTLY. OH NO. YEAH, he didn't say. He didn't
say. >> Give me your top three female streamers you When
he said that, chat, we all know who it was. And sadly, I'm going
to say it was Emmy.
Yeah. I guess this is the This is the Emiru fan phenotype, okay?
I Listen, Mizkif's not doing a lot of investigative work here,
but he is doing enough for my standards, all right? This He was
definitely This dude is disgusting. And the reason why he met
her is cuz we were both on the same plane as him.
love to date. Top three.
And Techtone is continuing to just ask him questions like a [__]
weirdo.
Okay, your number
Why is Mizkif pretending that he didn't do this exact kind of
content his entire
What is it that it's a fat ugly guy now, Mizkif? That's what's
putting you off? Well, you ask Alinity who she fantasizes about,
it's fine. You ask some only fans girl which streamer she wants
to [__] it's fine. But now it's some fat loser and
it's a problem.
>> streamer that you would date.
Emiru loves Emiru.
Okay. Okay.
He's farming too hard right now. He's farming too hard.
STOP. STOP. STOP. WHAT DO YOU MEAN? NO, THAT'S STOP. OH MY GOD,
NO. IS THAT IS THAT BAD? OH, BRO. OKAY. BAD. HE SAID ASK CLASH
OF CLANS. OH, IS THAT EVEN BAD? >> NEXT. NEXT.
There must have been some magic in that old silk hat they found.
So, Techtone came over. Him and Fream came over yesterday.
And the One of the first things Techtone says to me, he's like,
"What's up, dude? By the way, my 17-year-old father thinks you're
hot." And I was Yeah, so um I'm going to say this loudly.
Fream's going to Sorry, not Fream, but Pinky box this up with
private >> Improbably, I Okay, actually, Mizkif has definitely
watched some streams. He's watched the Shamoo video. He's watched
something to get informed, okay? Or somebody in his audience
has cuz he knows the talking points, okay? He knows it. >> I
heard from somebody very very a good source, uh the best source
I would say, that Techtone and his father would talk very disgusting
things about Emiru all the time.
All the time. Like Yeah, that's pink. That's pink. Thank you.
Pen pen, thanks for the 9 months.
By the way, my father who is a uh
a serial
thinks you're hot. Like dude, are you [__] kidding
me?
NO, IRON MIKE GETTING SHOTS NOW. IRON MIKE, NO. GET DOWN. OH,
Monkey's next to you. Yeah. He does mean Techtone, yes. He means
Techtone's father.
Convicted convicted sex assaulter.
Mike Robertson, okay? Michael Robertson.
Father of Techtone. Convicted sex
Stop military rape.com. Yes. >> This was before before
he was known,
You know,
it is.
Dude, did this guy just have a whole [__] docket
stashed away for a rainy day and then 2 hours into his stream,
he just decided, "I'm bored. Time to rape this guy."
>> Cuz he wasn't doing this content earlier in the day
and then out of nowhere, he's like, "You know what?
This guy. It's time for him to die." >> before it's known.
you know,
Miz would bot
What's this? Ready?
Found out that Mizkif WAS BOUGHT 14,000.
THEY HAD AN INTERVENTION SAYING, "You got to stop this [__]
cuz that looks
You know what's really interesting to me about this quote?
Why would Tectone ever hear about anything that goes on in the
OTK offices
in meetings with only org owners when Tectone at this point was
kicked out of the org? How would Tectone know any insider
that can't be leaked and shouldn't be leaked outside of the org
meetings?
Ooh, [__] Ooh, [__]
Mizkif's saying that Asmongold's telling him or someone's telling
him. >> know that?
Very interesting. How does he know that? >> It's an interesting
question to me. How would Tectone know that?
It's very interesting.
Very interesting.
How would he know?
Who's telling him insider information?
That's what I heard.
That's what I heard. Cuz could you imagine every single event
going to Mizkif's stream where he was botting that [__]
the whole time so all the viewers go to his and he says, "Why
would we do the event on your channel, bro? You don't get as
many viewers."
Yep. It's completely false. So, I'm going to say this right now
loudly and
I did events We got to get it on. >> 2019 until 2022.
None of those were botted and everyone knows that. That was real,
organic, real viewers. Yes. I had a lot of viewers back then.
It was the COVID times. It was every
And yeah, it made a lot more sense to be on my channel than yours,
Tectone. Because you're [__] No one cares about you.
And you want to know why it made more sense on my channel a lot
of times? Because my community was the nicest and most loving
community that everyone knew. And my community, what they would
do is they would actually stick around because I inherited a
lot of actual Twitch frogs.
Now, Mizkif probably had a really positive community. I will
say I met some of the I met some of the OTK OTK obsessed people.
All right? Those people go hard. I don't know if I'd say they're
the nicest people, but they're, you know, probably a smaller
percentage of that overall. >> that are there for not people
like Asmon who have only You want to know why we didn't do it
a lot on Asmon's? Because Asmon's community doesn't give a [__]
about anyone else besides Asmon. They don't care for anyone else.
They care for like five people and it's the people that he hangs
out with. That's it. They They don't care to to go in the the
trenches and find a Russell. They don't care to go in the trenches
and find someone else. They like five to 10 five streamers. That's
it. When my community knows everything, knows everyone because
I react and talk about it and I've inherited a lot of Twitch
organic viewers. So, we did it on my channel because when I would
raid someone else, they would stick. Because when I would I would
talk about other people, they would get viewers.
So, that's why we did it on my channel all the time. We did not
do it on your channel, Tectone. Because why the [__]
would we do it on your channel?
YEP. HEY, MIZKIF.
OH, I FORGOT
ABOUT THAT. HEY, TECTONE.
NICE TRY, TECTONE, YOU DUDE, I completely forgot about that.
I completely FORGOT ABOUT THAT, TECTONE.
I COMPLETELY forgot about that. Dude, this guy This guy has literally
hated streaming every moment every moment outside of the past
hour for the past year and a half 2 years, Mizkif has hated streaming.
He just found his like moment where he just loves it. He's actually
feeling himself right now, okay? He's feeling it. It's real.
He's back. Mizkif is back.
You absolute loser.
You had the most unique viewers? I did. I did. Was my [__]
botted after 2023? Yes, it was. I fully admit that. I know it
was. I Of course. I'm not stupid. But will I say my [__]
was when I was doing my content was ever botted? Never. I'd say
there was like five streams where I felt like my stream was botted
ever in my entire life that I feel like my stream was botted
from 2018
to 2022.
For those like five years where I was doing the OTK events and
[__]
Never was botted. Ever. Never. And then Tectone going around
saying, "Oh, dude, Mizkif was botting 14,000 viewers back then."
No, I wasn't. I wasn't. Sorry. Wasn't the case.
OH, MIZKIF'S DAD COMES IN FROM THE TOP ROPE. I NEVER HEARD YOU
say anything like that. I believe Mizkif's dad, okay? Mizkif's
dad believes in cut a wee bit of bleeds, okay? Mizkif's dad's
all right with me.
Dad, let me ask you a question. Who carried OTK?
I'll say it unequivocally. From what my viewpoint, from where
I stood, you absolutely, positively carried OTK. And you know
I don't throw compliments
Is this that the start and end of that?
That's just the truth.
I cared about that That guy's a reliable source. That's like
what my mom says, "I'm the handsomest boy, okay?" That's the
same thing. That's just facts, man. >> at org chat so much.
I would have calls for hours every day with Tips talking about
stuff, trying to figure stuff out, trying to figure out meetings,
trying to figure out things that we can possibly do to fix the
org, people we can invite, people we can have. I cared about
that org more than anyone else times 10. You add up everyone,
I cared about that org more than everyone times 10. I cared about
that org so much. I would tweet things, do things, do the sponsors
on my stream. Do the events on my stream.
Is that his I did it all. I did everything for that org. I really
did. I put my balls to the wall for that [__] Malena
Malena doesn't compare to me. I'm sorry, she doesn't. I would
say the
Okay. Sorry, I got to restart this just cuz compare to me. I'm
sorry, she >> bot stuff isn't quite fair. >> the
two people that cared about that org the most is me and Tips.
And I I I I I will say that and I don't I'm not a back up. not
a fan of Tips at this point, but I Me and Tips [__]
carried that org and cared more about it than anyone else. We
knew every single thing that went on in that place.
Every single thing.
I believe Mizkif cared. I also believe that Mizkif liked the
views from doing all the OTK stuff as well. I don't know. It's
somewhere in the middle. I don't know exactly where. I'll have
to see more information. Rich. He doesn't like Tips. I mean,
Tips did did just testify against him in his court case like
multiple times, provided all the evidence against him in the
court case, right? Tips is literally representing the other side
of the court case that Mizkif is pursuing. I don't think he likes
Tips, though.
>> carried that org and cared more about it than anyone
else. We knew every single thing that went on in that place.
Every single thing. Rich Rich Rich cared
but not like me and Tips. Me and Tips had meetings and calls
for hours. I would ditch friends for hours. Dad. And
Would I not ditch family time for talking to Tips? Uniquely.
And not And not only Tips, but anyone in OTK
who who who needed your advice or assistance. And I I remember
several times we were we were we were with you and we're sitting
there trying to have family time and you're talking to OTK members.
If you want, I'll name them. Name them. But Asmon for one. I
remember that. >> Yep. Asmon. Uh for for about reference
to merchandise. It was a long conversation and your mother and
I are looking at you like, "What the hell?" Uh that absolutely
No, Matt. I'll I'll credit you with that. You cared about that
org uh at at your own expense.
At your own expense.
I don't care about the fight. One person is just going to win
right now.
How are you supposed to feel if a guy who's abusive makes you
cry and then shoves your head in his crotch and demands you to
suck him off and his excuse is, "Emotion just turns me on when
you cry."
Wait. Was that a Was it that stretching or was that a reaction?
Hold on. Hold on. Dude, what the [__] >> makes
you cry and then shoves your head in his crotch and demands you
to suck him off and his excuse is, "Emotion just turns me on
when you cry."
Dude, his dad's reaction from the back. What the
Oh, his dad loves demon time, too.
I just
As a quick reference in case you guys forgot, I don't want to
take away from Mizkif's dad who is a character in and of himself,
okay? But just to remind you, this is who Pink Chew is, this
is who the allegation we're reading, this is who it's from, okay?
Just in case you guys forgot, this is who Pink Chew is, just
in case you guys forgot. I just need to make sure that you guys
understand that this is who it is. Okay? As long as you understand,
I can
Okay, we can continue. >> chat. This is the guy that attacked
me non-stop for years and said I assaulted Emiru. He said I'm
abusive. He said I'm a piece of [__] His best buddies
who are around him for his little show said the weirdest things
about him. And you know who platformed the living out of him?
You can take your Yes, on who platformed the [__]
out of him, who watches all his videos, who's hyper obsessed
with anything he says, who platformed him and gave him a YouTube
channel, who platformed him and gave him stream
That person
just had two of his best buddies canceled in 48 hours.
Oh, Asmongold, right?
said on her alts. And people [__] on her for it,
by the way. And people also He [__] on her for years.
He would talk [__] about her
Non-stop. Calling this lies. Saying this Saying [__]
about her that were lies, that weren't true. Just attacking her
like crazy.
crazy. What a monster.
They dogpiled me, [__] on me to the end of time on
Dude, Mizkif sees the vision. Mizkif has Either Mizkif's been
watching or some Mizkif fan has been watching the stream. He
understands it's insane for Teccy Tone to virtue signal with
the Emiru stuff when he's got far more plausible accusations
himself, right? And while whining about his own accusations.
It's
on her side and said Mizkif and made 17 videos about it to millions
of people and ruined my life and make people now when I go out
in public to bars call me a ra-
And people wonder why
It's because these people are hypocritical and just because they're
friends, they will protect people who assault women. Real assault.
Not
lies where someone read the room wrong.
assault. This is
I SWEAR TO GOD he's watching the stream. I literally used that
exact phrasing
Right? I USED THAT EXACT PHRASING.
I said everybody's read the room wrong. Oh my god. This is the
kind of [__] that people don't talk about. Why don't
you talk about this? Why are you defending this? Why do you protect
and promote this person who does like this?
Why do you allow it on your platform?
You're going to wait till the lawyer talks, right? That's the
big thing. You're going to wait till the judge gives his sentence.
Looks like he did.
Doesn't touch you. Doesn't have with you. Just keeps you around
as a [__] machine and degrades you. Makes you feel
ugly. Don't wear baggy clothes, straighten your hair, at least
wear eyeliner around the house. Your self-worth totally crushed.
I hate that people warned me. I didn't listen because I was so
manipulated. I hate that I was lied to and when another girl
who went through the worst tried to come
Me and her Oh,
[__]
Do you think Mizkif has the Fream files? I do believe the Fream
files are still sealed. Fream was very likely about to make a
allegation of sexual impropriety allegation against Teccy Tone
and then they settled their thing, they signed NDAs, they settled
their divorce, signed NDAs, and she went on her merry way. Okay?
But it's very likely, I believe we found this out with the Shamoo
videos, that Fream was almost certainly about to file some some
publish Sorry, publicize, publish some kind of in- impropriety,
you know, allegation against him. Mizkif tweeting incoming. Let's
go. All
Fream was about to was about to blow him up and then they settled,
they signed NDAs, and she went on her merry way, and we've never
heard about it. Do you think Mizkif has the deets? Does Miz have
the >> We're good now, but I shouldn't have listened. When
you're in it, you just feel blind to the reason. I see some comments
that are worried and I just want to let y'all know I'm out and
I have my own place and I'm safe. Don't want anyone to worry
anymore. I've been taking it one day at a time like this.
So, Pink said this almost 2 years ago. You see what I said when
court takes forever? She said this 2 years ago.
It took like a year and 2 months ago, Yeah, like a year and 2
months ago. 2 years. And during that 2 years, what did Teccy
Tone do? He didn't try to become a better person.
I think I think Teccy Tone talked about going demon time, actually.
Didn't Teccy Tone say he was a demon and and she got an aggro
on him? >> Teccy Tone didn't try to evaluate the situation
and maybe go, maybe I [__] up, maybe I need to do
better. Teccy Tone quadrupled down and made his entire platform
go from gacha games to just straight up being a right-wing
pusher. And by the way, I think some people are smart. Teccy
Tone is the biggest dumbass. How any of these people listen to
him? You're all All of you. All of you are for even watching
one of his clickbait videos about these people and taking anything
this guy says for word. He is the epitome of a dropout in high
school. He's a loser. He has no class, he has no education, he's
an actual [__] who just sits there all day and just
doesn't know what to say, so he copies Asmongold and makes a
way crazier take because Unfortunately, guys, we're now at the
point where we have to do some crazy [__] Okay? Let
me go over to Shamoo cuz I need to catch up on Mizkif. We're
going to take this timestamp down. We will come back to this
in just a second. But we got to go to a different Mizkif clip
over to Shamoo cuz we might have to go to Mizkif live right now.
It's very important, okay? Or at least going to have to go forward,
okay? sent
my ops to the courtroom for Teccy Tone and Pink Chyu. And I have
written down notes for a 7-hour trial. I didn't say a word last
night. I didn't want anyone to know. I have 7 hours of notes
on Teccy Tone and what he did to Pink Chyu. And I will be addressing
it all tomorrow.
Nice job, Teccy Tone. You
Way to talk [__] on people when you have your own
[__]
Okay.
We love Mizkif now. We love Mizkif. W Mizkif. Let's behind your
[__] back. You are a disgrace and you should be gone.
And your little come to Dude. Dude, dude, dude. Oh, you know
what? I'm not even going to skip
So, he latched on to Asmon over the past 2 the last tomorrow.
Here, hold on. >> Nice job, Teccy Tone. You dis- Oh, he's
right here. We were right there. We were right there. And I'll
tell you what's going to come tomorrow.
This is where we were. >> I sent
my ops to the courtroom for Teccy Tone and Pink Chyu. And I have
written down notes for a 7-hour trial. I didn't say a word last
night. I didn't want anyone to know. I have 7 hours of notes
on Teccy Tone and what he did to Pink Chyu. And I will be addressing
it all tomorrow. Nice job, Teccy Tone. You disgusting
Way to talk [__] on people when you have your own
[__] behind your back. You are a disgrace and you
should be gone. And your little buddies around you who constantly
claim wait till the court finds out, guess what? They're finding
out tomorrow. loser. And I can't wait till you're gone because
you've not only [__] over two girls, you [__]
over so many content creators just because you want your little
clicks and views. You're disgusting.
You are disgusting. And I'm glad people after a year and a half
will finally see the truth of you. I haven't said one word about
you and you won't shut the [__] up about me.
Demon time, so what I'm going to do tonight, chat? Probably get
one up vote on LSF for everything I just said. That's what You
know what they're going to say? Well, at least Teccy Tone's not
Mizkif, right, guys? At least this guy is not Mizkif. Oh, yeah,
of course. At least he's not Mizkif, right, guys? Sure, he just
got accused of assault in the courtroom, but at least he's not
You want to know why Teccy Tone deleted his thing today? Look
at this. Check this out. >> thank you very much. Mar dude,
thank you very much.
You want to know why he blocked me? You want to know why he just
deleted his video about him with guns? Teccy Tone was in court
today with five lawyers.
>> Five. Do you know how much it costs to have five lawyers?
Do you know how scared you must be to have five lawyers? My op
went in there, hidden, by the way. He had a hat on and he had
a COVID mask on. And he sat there collecting notes the entire
time while I was up all night with him knowing what the [__]
was going on and seeing the truth. Waiting to see what the judge
has to say. Teccy Tone, you little [__] who tweeted
today was going to be a good day, you lost the court case. You
want to know why you lost? Because you are a disgusting who actually
assaults women and you go on the internet and don't show your
side, you show the side that you want to show. You berate people,
berate women, and berate content creators all day to mask your
disgusting self you are. So, you buy a Labrador or whatever the
[__] this is, go on your right-wing and delete everything.
You tweet what a good boy he is cuz he's probably the only person
that looks up to you now, you ugly And by the way, Teccy Tone,
I'm going to add on to this, you're an ugly You are an ugly-looking
dude. You are ugly. You're an ugly man that needs to treat women
like that where you force them to suck because you're such a
pathetic [__] Yet, you attacked me for my
when it's just nothing. It's literally me reading the room by
accident, getting up and leaving. And that's the only time that
she had a problem. You know how many times in their 3 years of
you and Pink Chyu? How many problems she had? More than one.
She had a ton. Real [__] where you grabbed her head
and forced her to suck your You are a disgusting person and you
tell that you like it. You. And anyone that ever defended you,
any of your dumbass viewers on YouTube, and all your friends
that protected you for all these years who never questioned you,
who just let this go on and say they care about assault. You
don't care about assault. Any of the people that are around him,
you don't give a [__] about women, you don't care.
You care about taking people down that you want to take down
for clout. That's it. And you are the most disgusting, vile person
and I'm glad you're finally getting your peace. You deserve it.
You deserve everything that's about to happen to you, Teccy Tone.
You're a disgusting disgrace. And without your clout, without
your views, you're nothing. You are a loser. You're a bald 35-year-old
man that plays gacha games and reacts to Asmongold and takes
his takes and pushes it to the craziest extreme to try to farm
some extra views. You're a loser. You attacked Pokimane, QTCinderella,
Lacari, lawsuit, me. You attacked me cuz you know you'll get
views. And you just want to do it because you hate me. That's
it. You don't care about any of this [__] You don't
care about anything. You want to know why this is all a mask
because the truth is, Teccy Tone, you're the worst person on
this list. You're not even comparable to any of these people.
What's going on? for months, years now. On Hasan, farming so
much hate on the guy, acting like he's a problem. I remember
you on him for the brothel thing. You're going to [__]
on a guy who did the brothel thing, which was lies, yet you had
these accusations, Teccy Tone? Yet, you knew these were bad and
you probably were going to lose in court, but you farmed an audience
on this? This is you? This is who you are? You're farming hate
on HasanPiker all day, Frogan, people that are doing [__]
yet you have this?
You forced girls to suck your dick.
And you were in court over it? And I'm going to say this.
When I'm so You talk [__] about Hasan I'm shocking
his dog for months. For months you farmed that. Yet you have
you grab women, your girlfriend, and you force them to suck your
own dick, you
What's worse? Forcing a woman to suck your disgusting tiny penis
or asking your dog to sit still for 15 minutes? I ask you, Chad,
what is worse? Obviously Techtone is worse.
And you know what I'm so proud of with Pink Chyu, by the way?
And how if it's it's true. No one wanted to believe her. You
want to know why? Want to know why no one believed her? Because
she does OnlyFans. That's it. >> She does OnlyFans, so
no one believed her ever. She never got a chance for anyone No.
cuz she does OnlyFans. So when Techtone berated her on stream
constantly and [__] on her and made lies about her
constantly, >> We believe her. people were like, "Oh my
god, wow, she's an OnlyFans whore." Because he would call her
that. He would call her an Only We believe her. And people were
like, "Yeah, I hate OnlyFans [__] Wow, Techtone,
you're right. [__] her and I'm not going to listen
to anything she says." Because no one wanted to believe her.
But I did. And I knew. For a year and a half, as I let Techtone
[__] on me relentlessly, I was waiting for this day.
I was waiting for this exact day. Because I don't go after people,
chat. I never target anybody. In my eight years, I never go after
people first. I go after people when they go after me. And you're
one of those people, Techtone. And you are the second on the
door. Lacari was first, you're number two. And you're not going
to be number just number two. There's going to be way more. And
yes, people in Austin, you should be afraid of me. You absolutely
should. Let's go. >> every secret and everything about
you. You should be scared. Don't act like you shouldn't. I know
everything about you from the past eight years. I have all of
our DMs, text messages, things I know that you don't want out
there. Techtone's not the second. Techtone's not And guess what?
There's going to be a third, fourth, fifth. All right, I already
know who it is. >> Techtone is the second. >> You're
all last. Good job. Keep being
I'm over here by myself in LA chilling with all my friends. You
guys just continue to play your little
playmate toys over there and act like you're all friends. You
all hate each other, by the All hate each other.
But keep playing on it. Keep acting like you're friends and buddy-buddy.
Keep pretending that I don't exist. Keep acting like I'm not
in I'm not around. And stop [__] texting me She should
be your pain. night and today Raven Rubin donated $3.
Raven Rubin, read the room, man.
Act like you want to be my friend now that I have people in my
chat and people around me that know that I know the truth about
people like you. >> going off. Stop. [__] off.
I'm not your friends. I don't like you. You are not my people.
I grew all of you. I made you successful, but you threw me away.
You threw me away for the wrong person. You did the wrong thing.
And now, a lot of you're going to get what you deserve. Number
two is Techtone. Number one was Lacari. And we will see more.
I have more [__] on Techtone. I have more things
that are going on, but I can't [__] show it today
cuz I want to make sure that I have it properly.
But these are factual things.
Techtone went to court today and he lost the court case for sexual
assault against Pink Chyu. He lost. He lost the court case.
I'm pretty sure
I think it was for the protective order, but thank you. Mizkif,
he lost the protective order thing, I think, but It was civil.
It's okay. We're doing our best. >> the court case.
And Techtone has to pay
all of her legal fees for the past two years. Oh, is it the whole
civil? Wait. >> got a restraining order on him months
Do you know how hard it is to get a restraining order, chat?
>> how hard it is to get a restraining
Why do you think I don't have one?
By the way, it's been 3 months. Where's my restraining order
that you were working on? Wonder where it is. Thought I was a
stalker. I'm confused. Where's my restraining order? Dude, Mizkif's
kind of cooking here. Hold on. Mizkif's making a fantastic point.
It is really hard to get a restraining order, protective order
of any kind. What the [__] did Techtone do that he
got a restraining order, protective order against him? What kind
of sick [__] was he doing? It couldn't have been
the stream comments. I don't believe Trust me, if Pixie can't
get a protective order against Destiny for the stream comments,
then there's no shot that Pinky Chyu got one against Techtone
for his stream comments, right?
Techtone had to have gone way harder.
Way harder. >> Not weird. You just in front of 5 million
people said you're getting a restraining order. Where is it?
Anyone? Does anyone see it? Oh, it's cuz you made that up. Can't
get
what else was I going to say?
E Rob, you are blocked because No, it's not E Rob.
I'm telling you right now I will E Rob's my friend and that will
never happen
I'll give you the lowdown, the TLDR.
He wants to collab for an anti-Techtone
segment. Whatever you just said doesn't work. I've no idea what
this is.
Mizkif answers the call. Calls on Mizkif to establish a line
of communication so so he can best anti-
I thought today was a good day. What happened? The best
Does he hate Techtone or something? I don't know who this is.
Bazooka's does. And I do it yes as well. >> Chat, let me
say this. >> Me also. Techtone went to court today. >> I
sent someone to go to court
with a mask and a hat so they don't know who it is. If that person
Hold on. We're getting word, okay? We're getting word that we
have video footage of
Mizkif's inside man. Hold on. All right, guys. I'm ready to go
prove that Rapetone's a total Wish me luck, guys. Everybody,
wish me luck. This is who was in the court This is who it was
in the courtroom.
I'm going to get you, Techtone.
I'm going to prove that you're a rapist once and for all, Techtone.
This is the live footage, okay?
SHE GOT HIM. NOBODY WOULD KNOW WHO THIS IS. WHO could it be?
Who could it be? Hey, Techtone.
We're coming for you.
Yeah, THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT, TECHTONE.
WE'RE COMING FOR YOU.
Let's go. Person wants to come forward and say who it is, they
are free to do
I had them write down all the notes from For 8 hours they were
writing notes. They were writing things.
Why can't we upload it to the LSF thread? Go ahead. I have no
idea what LSF thread it is. Go ahead.
Oh, look. Mizkif's message to Techtone. Mizkif claims that he
has court transcripts from a trial involving Techtone. Are you
Look at this. Are you kidding me? LOOK HOW YOU'RE You're zero
and 73 for this? You were Tech Mizkif Techtone allegations. Let's
see the comments. Thanks, Miz, for the audiobook
Wait, he actually is.
Dude, LSF sucks. Dude, LSF really is brigaded to hell, right?
Bro, that's actually crazy. This is like the best drama ever.
And it's at zero upvotes? This is like the coolest thing somebody's
done in the drama sphere
since since Mitch Jones decided to rat Mizkif out, okay? Basically
Basically since Mitch Jones decided to rat everybody out. This
is the coolest thing that's happened in the realm of drama. >> from
15 months ago.
Are you [__] me? I just showed proof, you dumbass.
I just showed proof.
Don't worry about it. Like it's [__] insane to these
people.
This is It's [__] insane.
Mizkif needs to understand that LSF doesn't matter, though, okay?
Bro, I'm not the only one that's said Techtone was in love with
Emiru. Emiru knew that. >> Twitter It's not like this is
some wow surprising thing that he was in love with Emiru, that
Emiru wouldn't be like, "That's true. That's not true." Yeah,
we all knew that. It was very obvious.
It was a pretty easy one to understand.
Not that that was a big problem that I like hated Techtone over
that or had an issue with that. Um I don't really If you have
a crush on my girlfriend, it is what it is. But when you have
a crush on my girlfriend and you use that to ruin my life, yeah,
that's a problem. When you use that to vehemently hate me and
that's what your your reason is, yeah, that's an issue.
Okay. Real quick, I'm being told that eventually we are going
to stick on this, okay? Because I'm being told that
he actually pulls one of the videos up that's from the court,
okay? >> LSF bots. It's just hilarious. >> told that
it's not true. >> Whose viewers are they Whose viewers
are they, chat? Whose
Where I proven that he was a view botter, zero upvotes, no one
cares. Why did Techtone block me? Why did Techtone just delete
a picture of a gun? You might ask, chat, why did he delete the
picture of the gun?
Techtone went to court.
Techtone went to court
and Techtone had a restraining order on him for the past few
months. That's why Techtone wasn't streaming. Not because he
was clearing his mind, because Techtone wasn't streaming because
he had a Okay. This restraining order that Techtone had By the
way, hold on. It was just because he has no self-control, by
the way. Wasn't Didn't prevent him from streaming. It prevented
him from talking from seething about his ex-girlfriend,
okay? It prevented him from seething about this woman right here,
all right? It prevented him from seething about this woman right
here, okay?
If he could just go live without seething about this woman, then
he could be live. But he can't not seethe about her. So he just
stopped streaming instead. Back to Mizkif. >> Um it was
a few months ago, okay? He had a court today. And in court Techtone
was
tried for sexual assault.
Techtone, with his five lawyers It didn't go well. lost.
has not a restraining order
on from Pink.
He has the upgraded version of a restraining order.
Protective order. >> upgraded restraining order today.
Um I forgot what it's called. There's a name for it.
Protective order. Protective order. Protective order. A protective
order.
Let's go. >> Tectone has a protective order from Pinkchu.
For the next 10 years, Tectone can't own guns. That's why Tectone
deleted that tweet.
He's not allowed to own any firearms or weapons. Tectone is not
any allowed anywhere near her. Hundreds of yards he has to be
away from
And Tectone was a was accused and and the and the judge agreed
of the assault charges that Pinkchu had.
Five judges.
Tectone had five lawyers Tectone had.
She had one.
And she won.
That's how bad it was.
Get five lawyers.
You want to see something interesting and funny? I'm going to
show this and I'm going to I'm going to I do.
I DO WANT TO SEE SOMETHING interesting and funny. Cuz I I'm going
to probably want to end my stream soon.
There he is.
There's no way. There's no way. That sounds like somebody crying.
There If he had a video of Tectone crying
Dude, Tectone, I need to go take down that news tweet. That is
[__] up on my part, actually. If somehow that's Tectone
crying, I'm going to go take that tweet down cuz it's way too
real at this point.
There's no way.
It's not possible.
My dad just said if all the guys that I couldn't stand it was
Tectone.
Let's go. Dude, what was that video you pulled up? >> uncommon
statement. It's [__]
There he is.
Dude, we can hear it. That's him, right? That's the voice. He's
anonymous.
Ready for this?
There he is.
There's Tectone with some of his lawyers leaving the courtroom.
You can tell by his walk, you can tell by this. There he is leaving
the courtroom today. He gave me the kid. It's Tectone.
The walk of shame as he lost a court case to Pinkchu. >> Wait
a minute.
You can tell by his giant dome and who that walk is. Wait, is
this just a Mizkif? Is this just a Mizfrog who sounds super weird?
Okay, never mind. >> him. Oh, there he is. Tectone and
mocking him. I got it. Got it. Got it. There he is.
Audio's not Tectone. I knew it was too far. It was Dude, I had
to know that that was too far. Yep. He lost. He's anonymous.
For 10 years, he can't own a firearm, weapon, or gun, and he
has to stay away from Pinkchu.
And has to pay all of her attorney fees, which is hundreds of
thousands of
It's not a small price. And I'm sure Tectone had five lawyers,
chat, five.
I bet you he probably paid over a quarter million dollars plus
for the amount of lawyer lawyer fees, if not more.
If not more.
Mizkif claims Tectone left the court cuz Pinkchu said he has
to pay all of her legal fees. Yep.
I did.
Um It seems like the plausibility of the assault was supported
by the court as in they probably found it's likely he committed
the assault.
And that's why the protective order went through. And like that's
where I'm going. I think Mizkif's probably not wrong, but I do
believe this is almost entirely around the protective order.
I don't believe he's found been found civilly liable yet. Now,
he may have had to pay all of her lawyer's fees with regards
to the protective order. I think that's how this is going. And
yes, I believe he has to give up all of his guns. So, for me,
in my head, I'm like, dude, what the evidence does PinkyChu
BRO, WHAT EVIDENCE DOES BRO, SHE MUST HAVE CRAZY [__]
EVIDENCE, DUDE. >> Down vote the post to make Miz sad so
he'll just leak more. Nope, I'm done.
I've said enough today.
I said enough. All my other stuff will come out
I'm going to go drink with my friends.
Let's have a quick giveaway, chat. >> Let's go.
Giveaway? We're going to make this uh giveaway titled Tectone
Tectone sucks.
>> Don't DROP THE SOAP, TECKY. >> and we are going
to make this one Not a criminal trial, by the way. >> in
the chat.
There we go, boys.
We might get this, by the way. We might We might get this, chat.
I thought I have only a 1.5k viewers on livestreamfails. What's
going on? I thought you said I only have 1.5k viewers. What's
going on? Why Wait, are you A third of my viewers already are
participating? That's interesting.
A third of my viewers are already participating. It's crazy.
Dude, he just did like the most next
Bro, that's like better That's one of the best like character
assassinations I've ever seen in a stream.
That was like a crazy pop-off. That was like an such an iconic
moment. Of course he's got viewers right now. That was
Dude, holy [__]
I didn't say a word that I had that I had a guy going there.
I didn't say a word about the person that was in the courtroom.
I didn't say a word about the fact that there was a court case
today. I didn't want anyone to know. I didn't want anyone to
show up there. I didn't want anyone to bother them.
I'm just waiting to see if we get anything else. >> The
court case started at 6:00 my time. I was up till 8:30 in the
morning with him as he was sending me messages and information
about what's going on.
Yes. Dude, I knew it. I knew it. The whole time I was like, Miz
is right there. Miz is right there. The energy is right. The
energy is right. He's not getting everything correct. The energy
is so perfect, though. I can feel it. He's like he's onto something.
I can feel it. And then the faith is the faith is awarded.
All right, we just we just won. Miz won. We won. Everyone won.
Okay? Dude.
Whoops. I didn't even mean to pull it up that time.
Oh, wow. Half my viewers typed Tectone sucks. Damn, that's crazy,
right?
And it's interesting cuz like
I don't even give a [__] that Tectone botted. By
the way, I did not buy those bots. That was not my thing. I have
screenshots. Like I don't care. But when you go after people
and then talk [__] about people like that and just
ridicule them constantly and you're [__] putting
suck me and [__] You, Tectone. Like just [__]
you. It's the pot calling the kettle black or whatever it is.
Like He's anonymous. There he is. Bro, like half the platform
has bots. We know this. We're not
But that's not enough to be a piece of [__] This
is.
What happened?
Oh, we got to the end of the VOD. Hold on. I need to do this
real quick. Sorry, I'm doing something on the other on the on
the other on the other screen.
Everything he went after you for, he did. No, that's not even
true. Um I I I He He accused me of so much Dude, he accused me
Look at this. Look at this list. And this is all I know. I don't
even know if this is it. He said I I I He got mad at me because
I made a uh
I said he likes VTuber games and he he said I called him a pig
on stream, which by the way, I didn't.
I think I just looked at it and said, "Oh, look. Tectone would
like that." or something. Like Ah, you said a little more than
that, but it's fine. It's fine. All right. There's the tweet
right there. Okay?
Word on the streets is that this is the mass hero that Mizkif
sent to transcribe Tectone's court hearing today. I believe so.
Yes, I believe so. This is the one.
Yes. Yes, your honor. This is her. >> It was like something
such a minor joke, but then he does uh he does like those kind
of games, and then he attacked me for it, which then I
I apologized.
And he said it's okay.
Then number two is I made him pay $300,000 for a loan.
Chat, I hardly
Oh, Jake34, these cases probably are public. This case would
almost certainly be publicized. Like details of it would be publicized.
The outcome would be publicized. But it just might take a day
or two, especially cuz this was on a Friday. It might not It
might take till Monday or maybe in the end of next week for the
paperwork to get filed.
This is just like super up-to-date. If you saw the Shmue tweet,
he tweeted out that like he clearly knew that the case was going
to be scheduled today. Like it would have been on some docket
publicly today, but we just can't get all the public information
until it's filed. And because it's is a Friday, I'm guessing
that we just won't see it for a little bit, okay?
Here's what Here's what we had from Shamoo, that the the court
case was going to happen today.
Yeah, so it's a protective order case. Yeah, okay. Okay.
All right. All right. All right. Back to >> him for like
a month, and I wanted him to move cuz I liked him so much that
I gave him $300,000.
That's a lot of money for me. That's not some small penny. I'm
not I wasn't rich or anything like that. This is like 4 years
ago. I had money, but not That was like 10% of what I owned,
if not more. I gave him $300,000 cash when I could have used
that money in those 8 months or whatever it took him to pay me
back to invest in the stock market, to do anything else with.
I gave it to Teccy Tone because I wanted him to move to be near
me because
Didn't Mike say the five lawyer thing and celebrate before this
moment in the stream? Yes, he did.
Yes, he did. I heard about the five lawyer thing, okay? Possibly.
Possibly.
People People were talking.
But I don't know I don't know how to
Listen, people were talking, okay?
But you never say how you Listen, people Sometimes you just ponder
the orb, okay? And the orb reveals all to you. The orb just reveals
all, all right? I'm not going to say Mizkif was the only person
with this information. Sometimes the orb just reveals things,
all right? >> Cuz I liked him. Cuz he wanted a house in
my area. And he goes publicly years later and shits on me for
it, and lies and tells people that I made him pay extra for a
loan. When he's just a I I messaged Snack, and I was like, "Did
we make Teccy Tone pay extra for a loan?" You know what Teccy
He said to me cuz I was like, "Did we do that?" He's like, "No,
Teccy Tone's just an idiot and paid us only in PayPal, so he
paid all the
Who the [__] is running Teccy Tone's account where
they didn't They told him to do that? Like just wire the money.
Instead, he didn't wire it. He just paid it with PayPal like
an idiot.
Um He made Elon Musk rich. He made Elon rich. He hated me because
I was dating Emmy, true. He liked Emmy and he hated I was dating
her, like 100%.
Him and his dad would say weird [__] allegedly. Allegedly.
Dude, yeah. No No [__] PayPal fees for 300k is insane,
dude. Like that's That's ludicrous. That is not wanting to take
an hour to go to the bank, man.
Like you're doing If you're doing 50k installments, let's say
Dude, PayPal sometimes you pay up to like I guess if you don't
do any um
exchange rate, you probably don't get fees badly, but holy moly,
man. >> hated me He hated me because Russell threw a pool
party in my backyard, and chat, this is true. He I literally
shook his his girlfriend's hand, Pink She was ex-girlfriend,
and he then went around Austin and told everyone I grabbed her
hand for a long time, and it was weird, and told everyone I'm
weird as [__] for that, and making people hate me.
Then he said I'm the reason he got kicked from Only Fans, which
I literally proved to you that that's not true. That Chance is
the one that kicked him, and all I did was say, "What what should
we Just in case you guys forgot.
Damn, I have 744 people for a giveaway that I didn't even say
what it's for. Wait, I thought I bought 1.5k. I don't have 1.5k.
This. Teccy Tone, I have some advice for Mizkif with 2.6 million
views. Listen to this guy, ready? Remember the people that platformed
this guy. Remember the people that are his friends. Remember
the people that were around him as Pink She cried out and said
the accusations that she had. Neil on the stream. >> They
called her an Only Fans Remember this. Right now. >> I'm
watching. Um By the way, I haven't watched this, so let's hear
what he has to say. I do hope you take care of yourself, but
let's go. >> Thank you, buddy. I do. I know you're kind
of going down this route of you want to drop nukes on everybody
and watch the whole world burn, and that's all I have. That's
dandy. It's not really going to change anything, is
You scared, Teccy Tone? Is that what it was? Were you scared?
Were you scared?
Sounds like you were scared.
Not really. Um
You can do whatever it is you want to do, but my suggestion is
just that you simply retire.
That is the best thing I've ever heard in my life. Yeah, I know.
It's a good day.
I love today. Heard.
Dude, he just ran the greatest snarking operation of all time
on Teccy Tone with his dad as co-pilot. Holy
You know what he's doing here, chat? He's trying to manipulate
me and make people listen and say that I should retire because
he wants people to start saying that, so I think about retiring
and I don't go after him one day. That's what it was. He wanted
me to take the huge L to go, "Okay, Miz, you got accused of assault,
which I didn't do. You got accused of stalking, which I didn't
do. Your ex-girlfriend's getting a restraining order on you,
which she still doesn't have after 3 months, even though it does
not take that long. Um and uh she also said you were abusive,
which I never hit her or anything like that. And she you were
went around and basically ruined my reputation I worked 10 years
for and my
You shouldn't defend yourself, Miz. You should just go ahead
and quit."
Why would you say that, Teccy Tone? Why? Why should I quit?
Look how calm he is trying to act all tough and cool. Like he's
the cool guy that you get wise words from. Like he's
Uncle Iroh. Like this dude thinks he's a Buddha.
As if he wasn't just talking to 12-year-old anime girls a year
before this. It is disgusting. Let me pick it up for you a second,
Miz. Okay, it is disgraceful
that this loser with no life experience sits here, gets a loan
from Mizkif so he can buy a house, get on the property ladder,
okay? Done nothing useful in his life ever. Hawks
gambling to people on the internet. That's his job. He is a gambler,
okay? And he has the audacity to come out and say other people
should retire. Get the [__] out of here. Who is Teccy
with his bald ass head thinking that anyone should listen to
a word he
Look at him.
No one cares, Teccy Tone. Your ugly ass tattoo. You act like
a You act like a 12-year-old that likes WWE for a living. That's
all you act like. You're a little child that acts like you like
WWE for living, and everything about you is about John Cena.
Like you're a loser. You are a dork.
Move forward with your life. I did move forward with my life,
despite everyone around me attacking me and criticizing me of
false accusations. You know what I did, Teccy Tone? I went crazy
and I went on Kick, something I never thought I would do in my
entire life.
And you know what I did? I plotted my revenge, and I waited,
and I'm still waiting.
And you were the number two person on my
And look at you now, Teccy Tone. Go ahead and make this video
tomorrow. I would love to see it. >> Good buddy, and uh
you know,
keep on living. It's so funny how Teccy Tone was saying this
[__] when literally his girlfriend just got a restraining
order on him. Isn't that hilarious that he's literally trying
to give me advice
when um I still don't have that restraining order. He got a restraining
Do you know how hard it is to get a restraining order, chat?
It's not easy. You can't The protective order is particularly
hard. I'm going to say that again,
That the reason he was even making these videos, the reason he
had to go on this philosophical arc where he's like fixing himself,
is because he didn't have the self-control to not yap about his
girlfriend while he was live. So he went to making YouTube videos
that he could edit because he's a loser. You can't just be a
woman and say, "This dude's weird," and get a restraining order.
It's not how it works. It's very tough to get a restraining order.
Like it's so tough. It's not easy.
Then this guy got a protective order, chat. Do you know how hard
that is? Do you know how hard it is to get a protective order?
That Do you want to know why they took away his guns? Cuz they
think that he's going to do [__] with them. That's
how crazy it is.
Bro, in Texas, they took his They took his GUNS AWAY IN TEXAS.
THEY TOOK THEM AWAY IN TEXAS. What the [__] Dude
I'm pretty sure if you're like a You're I'm pretty sure if you're
You're allowed to have guns in Texas. Like I When did they take
your guns away in Texas, man?
It's really crazy.
Dude, I'm going to Just this is baseless speculation,
but like unless I see
This is baseless speculation. Until I see otherwise, I assume
he like threatened to do something, right? That's the only thing
that makes any sense to me. Now, that's a layman's point of view.
That is not legal advice. That is not true facts or anything,
but I just assume he threatened something with his weapons, then
that's why they took them. I don't understand how they could
ever take his guns like that for 10 years if he hadn't done some
[__] like this.
It's a federal crime to possess guns if you have a protective
order against you. Okay, maybe it's just the level of um protective
order. I don't know, man. Holy [__] Dandy, it's not
really going to change anything, is it?
Not really. Um
You can do whatever it is you want to do, but my suggestion is
just that you simply retire.
Tweet this video
back at this right now. >> Miz, in case you're watching
this.
I do hope you take care of yourself. I do.
Dude, I can't hear I can't hear Miz's dad. I'm going to rewind
it here. We got to hear Miz's dad here in the background. Give
me a second. We got to turn it way up.
I will say this.
Whoops. Miz, in case you're watching this, um
I do hope you take care of yourself. I
His dad His dad must be talking to somebody else. Blonde hair,
blue eyes? What are you talking about back there?
You planning a superior race or
I don't know, but I will say this. Miz, in case you're watching
this,
I do hope you take care of yourself. I do. I know you're kind
of going down this route of you want to drop
if only I'd been pursuing that Polymarket sponsorship, Trucker
Joe, we could have absolutely made a pool on this. Oh my goodness.
Why did I not pursue the Polymarket sponsorship? I needed so
bad.
nukes on everybody and watch the whole world burn
that's fine and that's dandy. It's not really going to change
anything, is it?
Whoops. Didn't mean to click that.
Hey guys, please hit like on the video as it helps the channel
in the algorithm. If you want to support more
OH MY GOD, he just opened the Shamoo
Dude, there's no way. Oh my god, 2026
is
Oh my god, I can't even Dude, I can't even. I I literally can't.
What?
Let's go. >> content like this >> Hold up. What is
this video called? Hey guys, please hit like on the video as
it helps the channel in the algorithm. If you want to support
more con
Twitch's most abusive
>> us. We've been together
We'll watch this tomorrow.
He looks kind of intelligent. Let's go. Post the video of him
walking out of
Dude. Can someone uh grab this for me and slow-mo it and say
hello put hello darkness my old friend and just slow-mo it with
gray and white.
Now he's directing film. Let's go.
Can someone else I mean my my guy was terrified of this. Like
just slow it down right here.
So, I don't know, Trucker Joe. I'm guessing he'll have to figure
out That is a good question. I'm guessing that he will have to
figure out how to just stream without talking about her.
Right? Cuz I don't think it really prevented him from streaming.
That I don't think that exists in the United States. That they'd
say you're you're not allowed to stream anymore because of this
protective order. I think it was that he wasn't supposed to talk
about her publicly, make publicly disparaging statements about
her. But he couldn't help himself from doing it, right? That's
the problem. Remember when we were just following his streams
and he would just seethe about her? Like he'd do a 4-hour stream
and he'd just freak out about her the whole
What do you guys think, chat?
Look at LSF.
He's got to be top of LSF now. >> make a book, by the Give
our boy his due. He's got to be top of LSF now.
Jesus Christ, man. Tectone doing the walk of shame and leaving
the courtroom.
I actually think I'm not kidding you, chat. We can make a [__]
TV show out of my my career. I'm going to be real with you. I
think my career can be a [__] TV show.
Like it's wild.
It's wild.
Uh I had to throw this one out, okay?
I just I think we can all We can all agree, all right? We can
all agree.
I will never mock demon time ever again, okay? There's no more
of the There's no more mocking of demon time.
He delivered. He stood and delivered,
We got to We got to give it up to him, okay? This one time we
got to We got to give it up to him. We got to give it up to him,
man.
Like good. Okay.
wild my career. It's been insane and it's not over despite the
fact that Tectone wanted to pretend.
It's not over.
It's a your ego It's not an ego thing. It's a sad thing. I wish
my I wish my career wasn't like this. You think I like this?
I wish it wasn't the truth.
Do you not like this, Mizkif? Mizkif, the first time you came
back, you were
You were totally Your brain barely worked. You were You were
depressed.
But you had three or four times as many viewers. Would you rather
that or would you rather this?
You're in the [__] driver's seat. You're making moves.
You're making things happen.
Dude, [__] whatever you were before, okay? This is
a way better existence. Who gives a [__] about the
guy you were? That would have been the most big loser existence
ever, okay?
It's demon time now. This is a different Mizkif, okay? It's not
the same career. It's not your career as in anywhere else. This
is a new career. You are starting a new career right now. Make
the most of it, okay? I wish we can all be friends. I wish none
of this [__] happened. I wish we all could be in
Austin hanging out with each other. I I I hate this. I hate this
a lot. I don't wish this was This was my [__]
There is no no. He's
Burn the [__] boats, Mizkif, okay? You're a Viking
raiding party. You just came ashore.
There's no going back, all right? Burn the boats. There's no
going back. It's victory or death now, okay?
Burn the boats. It's You're all in.
But I will say this.
Thank you, Kick, despite the fact that I shunned you for years
taking me in. Thank you, the Twitch Kick community, for letting
me have my [__] And I also want to say
thank you to um the viewers here and the chatters here who are
very easy to deal with, very good, caring people that
that that seriously are, you know, in my opinion, I think they've
realized the [__] truth and they don't realize the
lies that are perceived about me all around the internet. They
They really understand that I'm not this devil that they want
to pretend. They want to push agendas on me because they [__]
hate me for whatever [__] reason, but they ruined
my life over it.
I'm not pretend I'm I'm not going to pretend I'm perfect. I'm
not going to pretend I haven't [__] so many times,
done stupid [__] gotten angry over for nothing for
dumb reasons. But I'm not a I'm a human and I'm a human that's
been stressed out and dealt with a lot of crap including getting
canceled for and now to deal with [__] for for 2
years. Like it sucked. It Dude, can we >> really sucked.
I have no doubt it sucked. We'll listen to Mizkif in just a second
again, but very critically, way more than LSF.
Where's the premier drama account? We got some premier drama
account clips
Here we Okay, let's go.
We finally got it, okay? It just came
It just came out.
Dude, I'm I'm just throwing it out there, okay?
we were suspiciously lacking in clips on this, but now we got
one, all right? We got some clips going. Bro, this is the most
insane drama.
This dude, it's crazy.
The fire The fire of human liberty go through his veins.
OKAY? WE'RE SETTING FIRES EVERYWHERE. I WAS DEPRESSED. I was
I've never felt the same after those days. It's I still don't.
I still don't.
I'll never I don't know if I'll ever feel the same for what I
did from from those years ago.
you just keep going, you know? But that's all you can [__]
do, but it's it's just crazy to me. You know? I don't wish this
was my life, but this is my life. And do I think it's insane?
Yeah, it's [__] insane.
But if I'm going to get called out and accused of I'm going to
take down the people that actually deserve to be taken down.
And you know what's the crazy part? It's a lot of the people
that attacked me. It's a lot of the people that sided with Austin
streamers that go after me, criticize me. When you shouldn't
be doing any criticizing yourself.
I believe people can change and I believe people can move on
and do things do stupid things uh and and change as a person.
I do. And I I and I I fully believe that. And I think you all
do, too, cuz I think you guys have noticed that I've changed
a lot over the years. I used to be hyper obsessed with viewership
and care about that all day, every day. That's all I would talk
about and care about. It's not like that anymore. It's That's
been like that for over a year. I I just I I don't know what
it what's been, but I just I really just don't care.
Like I just don't.
I care, but not in the level I used to care where I was obsessively
going on Twitch trackers all day and doing things. Not that I
even think that's that big of a deal, right? Is it a big deal
that someone who loves football and and and and is a pro football
player watching routes and seeing what other teams are doing
and talking about analytics on players? No. Why is it a problem
that me and Nick like Twitch tracker? Who cares? It just makes
no sense, but they just belittle and attack me for it, claim
me I'm some hyper obsessed loser that can't stop reading
Mizkif has only changed cuz he was forced to. I don't know if
you know this ADHD ADHD runs me, but that's basically true for
every person above the age of like 18.
People only change when they're forced
But you also learn a lot about how people can change when they're
forced to, okay? I personally, and I'll be the first to admit
it, at first I didn't believe that Mizkif
would make a comeback. I thought he was going to break down.
I I doubted demon time specifically. I thought he could come
back and then he sort of he did his one stream and then he sort
of faded out and I was like, "That's what I expected." Then when
he came to Kick
and he started grinding, my attitude on him changed entirely,
okay? But he did have to change. It My attitude on on him changed
entirely when I saw the work effort the work ethic, okay? The
effort he was putting in. Then I'm like, "Oh, now this could
be something." I He was so used to getting it easy and now he
had to put some work in and he was putting the work in. There's
not a lot of people with the drive when they when they get in
something for free, right? When they get in something really
Not a lot of people will go back and start working super hard
for that same amount or less. He's probably making way less money
than he made before and working four, five, six times as hard,
his own [__] >> Who cares? Who gives a Skip
this. What is this?
I think content creators and there's a few of them especially
now that they know that they should be scared. Um want me to
die. They hate me. They don't like who I am as a person. They
think that I uh ruined them for some reason they put all the
blame on me for some reason because I think I'm the center. And
um they have ruined my life and I think they want me to die.
Like there's no reason to go after me the way they did. They
want me to die.
I understand why you're apologizing and you're not doing this
because you're in the right. You're doing this because you're
small. You're
Oh my god, ain't no way brother man Ain't no way brother man
Bill. You're a When was this? Right after I got canceled. afraid
and you're lashing out the only way you think that you can and
it's embarrassing. It really is and it's a shame because as the
most eager Lowering my what? You're lowering yourself to his
level with slimes [__] Because I This is great. This
is the greatest
Dude. Did you hear that question? I'm going to rewind it so you
can hear that question one more time, okay? >> shame because
as the most eager Lowering my what? You're lowering yourself
to his level with slimes [__] Because I This is great.
This is the greatest day of my life.
Yeah. Hey. Shoot that guy. This guy? Yeah, him. The SS [__]
with a busted wing.
Did you hear what this guy just said to Mizkif? This guy just
said, "Why are you lowering yourself lowering yourself to
And Mizkif,
demigod that he's slowly becoming, responded, "What are you talking
about? This is the best day of my life."
Oh my goodness. I
Dude. as the most eager Lowering my what? You're lowering yourself
to his level with slimes [__] Because I This is great.
This is the greatest day of my life.
Okay, you said everything that needs to be said. No, but now
I get to watch this bull I haven't seen what he said about me.
pistical person I
Dude, why are you lowering yourself to this? This is the greatest
day of my life. What are you talking about lowering myself? And
I tend to agree. This is the best content Mizkif's ever
This is by far the best solo content Mizkif has ever produced.
It's not even close. ever met you think you'd have >> This
was after your lawsuit was >> but you don't. You're just
a small small man and everything that comes out, the hair transplant,
the steroids,
the begging streamers to collab and then calling them a leech
is just for optics.
Mizkif, everything you do is to inflate your already overinflated
ego to make up for your lack of self-worth because you have none.
True.
And I think Okay, I just real quick I have to point out I do
not believe that was Mizkif's dad. I think that's There's another
guy there for sure. I do not think that was Mizkif's dad that
he just spoke to. I don't think Mizkif I think Mizkif's dad actually
gets it. I think Mizkif's dad had to be there with him when Mizkif
was struggling and see these dudes think about how your parents
see you and when like one of your friends you over, think about
how your parents think about that guy. I'm pretty sure Mizkif's
dad gets it. I'm pretty sure Mizkif's dad's sitting there like,
"No.
Take him out. Take him out with the knees, son." This really
goes to show just how embarrassing this entire situation is and
honestly I do think you should be ashamed of what you're doing
right now. You're right, Teccy. I should be ashamed. Aw, poor
Teccy. You will not win. This will not end in your favor and
you are completely yourself. Mhm.
I'd say it something to Emmy and Asmon but I'm sure they're fine.
I guarantee you they don't give a [__] cuz this is
the most embarrassing lawsuit I've ever
You know what? I Today I'll allow it. Today Today I'll even rewind
it and watch it again, okay? I'll allow it. I'll allow it.
Oh, amazing stuff. Amazing stuff.
Yeah, I saw this. This to me is a nothing burger. This is basically
Asmon saying whenever it's over he'll talk about it. Like whatever.
That was the Yoko Ono thing. That was the Yoko Ono thing. >> Also
I'm pretty sure he's in like three different lawsuits right now.
Someone said he's in like one like need to win. I don't [__]
know.
Yes, Teccy had five lawyers. Five.
And she had one.
And it was a woman.
And guess who won? The woman.
If Mizkif goes live tomorrow
and just drops like all the notes that includes like the evidence
the the evidence they introduced and like how the judge rules
on it, Oh my god, it's going to be the best day ever.
It's going to be the best day >> Okay, he had five lawyers
voice five.
It'll be even better.
If if Dude, if Mizkif has the notes he says he has,
it will be even better tomorrow.
That's That's a big number.
Don't you have four? It might have been a lot more trouble if
he only had one.
Listen, Teccy had the [__] Exodia of lawyers, chat.
But I have a lawyer I have the Exodia of lawyers with uh yamakas.
I got Bergstein's left hand. Steinberg's right hand.
Five V one is crazy. How the [__] did you Goldstein,
Silverberg. How did he lose to five lawyers? That's insane. I
know. Come on. And he's probably got so much more money than
him. Yeah, I mean listen, like people can win in court cases
by just having a better lawyer. Like that's 100% true. Like it
is. Like you can win a court case by having a a better lawyer.
But the odds were stacked against her. >> He's definitely
winning this assault case of of of actually Okay, this is it's
so impossible.
And she won. Like it that's insane. She won.
Her proof must have been damning.
It was.
I can explain.
I can explain. I actually Okay, I can explain. Classic.
Miz, your biggest hater was your biggest fan. He only had good
things to say about you after he left OTK.
Who's that?
Wait, what is this? Hold on. Yeah. Somebody pointed out, okay?
In real time. The nothing The nothing ever happens Chud.
Struggling mightily, okay? We have to put this guy to sleep forever.
This guy's This guy's January 2026 has never been worse. This
is This guy's January is the worst in his entire life, all right?
This guy's getting put down this month.
January 2026 is the death and total defeat of the nothing ever
happens Chud, okay?
We're back.
It's not plugged in. It's not even It's not even It's not even
plugged in. It's not even plugged in. It's not even It's not
even plugged in. We would play like Mario [__] tennis.
It was awesome. It was awesome. Along the way, things got a little
muddy. I'm not going to lie, things are probably still muddy
to today. I don't really care. It is what it is, but Miz was
good to me. All things considered, I mean obviously he would
make a lot of jokes at my expense. Sure, I didn't appreciate
him him insinuating that I was a That was weird as [__]
But, other than that, it was fine. You know what I mean? Like,
we were good, we stopped being good, but I don't I don't hate
the guy by any means. It is what it is. So, before
11 months ago, you didn't hate me at all and said it is what
it is. And then you made like 12 videos on me, 400 tweets, and
a partridge in a pear tree. Like, it's very interesting.